I
haven't last
time with my name
because I'm a humble person. I don't
want to be portrayed
as crazy.
game to come here and
to no
with you have to be careful. What's your
name? Sorry. Sydney, my name is Shi.
Sydney, you have to be cautious here. I
mean like speak for me myself. I have
people that try to my name too. You
understand? Trying to speak things out
my context. Even they try to claim that
I'm against Palestine. I'm a Muslim. You
know what I'm saying? And I have video
defending videos no videos defending
outside. So this is the mush the problem
of
speaking you have to be very
cautious
people I want to ask a question
about
versat I don't
mind Having seen you on a video on
YouTube, you're the only one I respect.
Thank you very much, man. You're the
only one that's humble enough that
actually cares about someone. If you
want a spiritual religion, you do it in
a loving way and you care about
religion, not that's right. That's
right. You're the only one I can see
that
alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah the
teaching I follow Islam is a teaching
which we
call means I follow the teaching of the
disciples you understand so so when I
come here I mean I'm not perfect myself
I get angry you know follow but I always
try my best to keep everything like when
people tell me come debate show people
not scared I don't debate cuz right I'm
not here to show people are not scared
I'm here to please Allah I believe that
even debating is part of Islam
conditions of course. So I agree some
people you know that even among the
Muslims they come here just for views
they come here for getting videos virus
and everything and this this this
Islamic teaching and even there's a
narration our prophet Muhammad taught us
on the day of resurrection the first
person that would be punched in the fire
someone that was teaching Islam imagine
this he was teaching Islam and he was
why he was doing it for showing off he
was not doing it with Allah the second
person someone despise jihad you know
jihad he was doing jihad but he was not
doing it for the sake of god he was
doing it to show people that he's brave
he's not scared you understand the
attack of the person will give you
charity to show off so showing off is
very is a mistake this is what Jesus
said if you fast don't tell people
you're fasting when you pray go to your
room and pray don't pray in the public
like the hypocrite yes yes that's why
Islam yeah Islam does agree with his
statement in one aspect there's two type
of prayer there's There's voluntary
prayer which is you should not be doing
it for people do it like night prayer
says night prayer do in hiding time like
it's the night time charity which is not
compulsory because it's compulsory
you're not showing up you got to do it
but if it's voluntary prophet Muhammad
told us even the Quran to do it in
secret that's why the scholar said which
one is much better when it comes to
voluntary charity to do it for everyone
or in secret it's a defense if you're
going to do a photo with everyone and
they will encourage to donate is good
you see but if you think you need to
front everyone affect your heart if you
need to show off don't do it you see so
so that's why we say to you you know
that's why but Islamic teaching the most
important thing is the one
support that's I don't want I know you
don't said you want to discuss off the
you discuss off camera I don't mind
speaking to you off camera
100% yeah I just want to talk to you
to one. Uh